[Music]
good evening and welcome to fox news
primetime
i'm trey gowdy thank you for watching
your time is important
and we're grateful you would spend it
with us i want you to imagine there's a
foul
sitting on a prosecutor's desk the
decision
that prosecutor makes will impact every
aspect of your life
your reputation is at stake your freedom
is at stake
your ability to provide for your family
is at stake now
what are the characteristics and
qualities you want in the person
making these decisions that will impact
your life
you want that person to be impartial you
want that person to be fair to be guided
by the facts in the law
you want that person to protect the
confidentiality of the investigation
because even rumors about your case can
impact your reputation
you want someone who values the truth
you want someone with the courage to
make the right decision even
if it's an unpopular decision
there's an old supreme court case that
sets out the job description of a
prosecutor
it is not to win it is not to simply get
convictions
it is to be a minister of justice
i have a daughter in law school and
she's heard me say this a million times
good prosecutors clear more innocent
people in a month
than defense attorneys do in a lifetime
but you have to be objective you have to
be fair
and you have to be honest
i would be hard-pressed to think of any
lawyer i work with in congress
who is less qualified to be a prosecutor
than adam schiff yet this week we
learned he wants to be the next attorney
general of california
i get that california is progressive i
get that the next attorney general there
will not share any of my political views
i'm fine with that
but you can still find someone honest
and fair and trustworthy
there are plenty of progressives who
still value the truth we had one on last
night
tulsi gabbard there are others
but adam schiff is not one of them here
is just one example
there is circumstantial evidence of
collusion there is
direct evidence i think of deception
this is about as clear
evidence you could find of intent by the
campaign
to collude with the russians the
russians offered help the campaign
accepted help
the russians gave help and the president
made full use of that help
the best case that the president is not
an
asset of the russians is the russians
would tell him slow down
you're too obvious
none of that was true
it was a lie good prosecutors don't lie
he prom adam schiff promised evidence he
never produced he leaked
witness interviews he did everything he
could to cover up the fisa abuse
he even went to court to keep you from
finding out who paid for the dossier
he claimed he had never met with a
witness but we know he had
and when his facts weren't good he made
up new ones and when he got caught
he called it a parody if the democrats
were really worried about disinformation
they would have shut adam schiff up a
long time ago
when it came time for the grand jury to
meet
adam schiff could not convince a single
republican house member
to vote his way he couldn't even
convince all the democrats to vote his
way
and when it came time for the senate
trial he failed to persuade
the jury he didn't even come close
i know cnn thought he was dazzling but
trust me
losing the way he did is not dazzling
so now he wants to be a minister of
justice
he wants to be a prosecutor he wants to
be the top prosecutor in the state of
california
i can name dozens of democrat lawyers i
would trust
to sit at that table and make the right
decision
on a case that impacted my life
but adam schiff is not one of them
california's next attorney general will
be a progressive
i know that but why can't it be an
honest progressive gavin newsom is the
governor of california
at least for now he is he gets to pick
the next attorney general
here's to hoping he picks a woman or a
man worthy to be called
a prosecutor worthy of being called
a minister of justice